you know how I became a Lego these
beautiful five foot seven you know the
figure for days blonde hair blue eyes
they come and they go hey Polly do you
want to try out to be a Laker girl with
us and I'd look up at them I go no like
why not
because I'm I don't look like you and I
don't fit the mold but you're so good
Paula come on what do you have to lose
and that was a challenge Miss nothing I
suppose and I remember on my toes and
I'm I'm hitting my hips and they go okay
if we call your number please step
forward and numbers are being called and
then two of my friends like one after
another got called and I'm going and I'm
like yeah like that and then my numbers
called and the other two girls weren't
call and I'm just going oh my God and
I'm on my tip toes they go uh state your
name I go Paula Abdul spell it abdull
like Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
sure whatever